we bring in Reggie Miller reg do you
care about the Rams being in Los Angeles
say how important is that team to Los
Angeles right now well it's important
just for the simple fact it seems like
football is our new American pastime so
to have an NFL team here it's a big deal
if you're asking me personally am I do I
care about the Rams no I we spoke about
this before number one I'm a Raiders fan
first and foremost Lester Hayes and you
know John Madden and Ken Stabler and
those you know Raiders teams when they
were here in Los Angeles and second you
know my adopted you know Colts so do I
care that the Rams are here it's great
for the city you know building that nice
new arena out there by the airport where
the old form around that area it's nice
but you know obviously Jeff Fisher and
that news is big here because of really
everything that's been going on between
Fisher and eric dickerson yeah that's
the bigger news is you know obviously
the fire ring but the bickering that's
been going back and forth with the Hall
of Fame running back and Jeff Fisher
probably has been I mean like you know
Housewives of Los Angeles ish here
between those two but when you call a
game with the Pacers have you ever been
critical of the Pacers or front office
or draft picks sure oh sure absolutely
I've gotten calls from David dinner and
I've had conversations with my owner but
you're doing your job you know I call
what I see that's all I can do and
there's other times when people claim
I'm being a homer and there's times when
people are saying how could you say that
about the Pacers my job is to call
what's in front of me and what I see you
may not like it it's my opinion but I've
got to call what I personally see and
there's been times when I've been
critical and there's been times when
I've you know applauded what the Pacers
have done yeah I was wondering about
that where people expect you to say
something nice about the Pacers because
you spent your whole career there and
here's Eric Dicker's youth okay
sides there is Eric Dickerson as an
analyst who's covering the Rams going to
be critical of them or should he be more
of a homer and covering them what he
would be a homer if he's announcing rams
games only well Eric Dickerson is
talking about the NFL at large so he has
to be straight down the middle and call
what he see so I'm on Team Eric
Dickerson here because he's talking
about the NFL in general and the RAM
stink and everyone see what Erich is
saying is what everyone was thinking you
know where are the pictures he must have
something else no wonder they've got to
keep his job for this long and that's
what people you know in small circles
have been saying about Jeff Fisher
Reggie by the way we'll have the Bulls
at the Bucks thursday night at eight
Eastern on TNT do you see Brady last
night yelling at Julian Edelman on the
sideline yes and and what's funny about
that is to me that's just perfection and
wanting to get things done right and I
think a guy that as you mentioned
earlier very well could be win another
nvp he wants things right and the people
in the locker room Elliman Brady and the
coaching staff and the players they've
let this go you and I and the rest of
America we're the only ones talking
about it because in the heat of the
battle it's all about winning it's all
about being is all about you know
winning another Super Bowl and I think
Brady has earned that right because we
do not know what has gone on throughout
the week in preparation for that game
last night vs baltimore maybe element on
that particular call or whatever messed
up and you know they went over it and
over it and over it and I think Brady's
frustration probably got the best of
them but I don't take anything from that
Brady has earned that right and to me
it's all about perfection well let's say
Dez Bryant did that would we let him get
away with it where would we be it
critical did that to who Dez Bryant no
Dez Bryant
I'd say does Ryan did that on the
sidelines to one of his teammates let's
say yelled at dak Prescott okay but it
depends on who the teammate is Edelman
and Tom Brady they have that special
relationship and both have years in the
league now yes Brian is doing that to
Ezekiel Elliott or dez bryant two
rookies now that's a little bit
different in my opinion but I know those
two guys need a little bit more
nurturing as opposed to you don't you
don't have to hold the hand of Julian
Edelman but did you yell at teammates
yes I when you're a leader of a team you
have to but you got to know what people
to yell at you never yell at the right
people and you have to be able to say
the right things at the right time it's
not about screaming and yelling and
Brady knows he's on national television
he knows all the cameras on on him you
think you you think he wants us talking
about this it's about getting your point
across to the right person you don't
think Jill Julian element can handle
tough talk from Tom Brady yeah I'm sure
he can I think the big leap answer what
you say and who you're saying it too
though I think those two guys have a
special relationship obviously receiver
quarterback and they've been through the
fire they've won the Super Bowl together
they understand one another they've
moved on we just have it that's all
that's it's a talking point for us
baseball is going to get rid of hazing
on road trips with rookies what kind of
hate and what we live in a politically
correct society nowadays and I get what
Major League Baseball do it which means
now that NFL and the NBA the NHL is
going to follow suit because we have so
many kids that watch as you mentioned
you know rookies being tied up to the
goalpost getting their hair cut we had
you know when we make rookie sing happy
birthday things like that you would
dress them up young kids are seeing this
and with hazing and bullying you know
being front and center now you know with
young kids taking their lives because
because of
bullying and hazing I think professional
sports teams are probably starting to
take notice of this and trying to cut
back a lot of it is good-natured and fun
but at the end of the day it is hazing
and how we live in such a politically
correct society today I mean you know we
used to my thing as a rookie you know
Wayman Tisdale herb Williams Chuck they
may be gone get us a today's get them
coffee I had to go wash their car that's
on hazing that that's not hate right
that's how your rookie your rookie thing
I don't know what haziness were filling
up a rookies car full of popcorn is that
hazing a little bit a little bit right I
remember going to the Spurs camp when
Tim Duncan was there as a rookie and he
was carrying everybody's bags you know
they made him because he it but he that
he understood it he was like yes this is
what you're supposed to do I'm a rookie
I have to earn my way in gotta earn your
stripes yes I remember like in Detroit
or Cleveland arriving at three or four
o'clock in the morning when it's 20
below as a rookie having to go out and
get those bags with the trainer and any
other rookies and I just kept saying to
myself it's one year and then you're
done it's one year and then you're done
everyone has to do that and you don't
try to pile on to the rookies or new
players but it is a rite of passage is
it is it right is it funny at I'm sure
it is can it cross the line I'm sure it
has no it almost feels like it's not a
rite of passage they're saying it's a
wrong of passage so we're talking to
Reggie he's got Thursday night the Bulls
at the bucks at eight Eastern on TNT do
you see Chauncey Billups said some of
his teammates played better after
smoking pot well one of that was during
the game of the mouth of the palace that
he saw a few though guys were probably
looking pot that night well I was in
Detroit and I was uh I was walking by I
was with John Barry we're doing a game
and I walk by and one of the Pistons and
you smell too sticky icky oh oh you're
talking like actually before yes like
that yes I got those comments
were like earlier like you know during
the day you mean like if the game is at
eight without like 630 yes yes yes you
know like a pig pen Charlie Brown sort
of had that feel when you walked by one
of the players well that explains a lot
now I'm back to my original what I
originally thought that was a goaltend
by tayshaun Prince man because that was
some of the smoke then watch that back
know that well that's a goldfish back to
that original before i was given them a
pass but now in light of this new
information that has provided us by the
way bird just need bird turned 60 and
that amazing Bernard's gotten old well
father time will eventually catch all of
us but it's hard to think i just i
remember sitting in my dorm at UCLA and
watching those great series between
Boston and magic and bird and magic is
my mentor I said this on this show
before but I patterned my game who I
wanted to be like who I wanted to play
like after Larry Bird's I was torn so I
love them both but and have a chance to
play against Larry early on in my career
and then kind of be under his leadership
when he took over as head coach it was a
thrill for me because that was you know
one of the players that you know I
really idolized and pattered my game
after ya turned 60 I just saw that they
sent on a highlight reel NBC did he just
wise well a bad boy man was ten people
forget how good and the younger
generation needs to go back in YouTube
man some of the stuff that kid did man i
should say kid that man that man did it
was a bad boy but it was always and you
could get racial you know go down racial
lines there you know like black guys
saying aw birds not that good you know
then you'd have to defend it but you
know no bird can play and then magic
came out
no no he can play it's like it was just
this dividing line where people were
arguing if bird was actually overrated
because he was going to get awards
because he was white I just remember
that was always a topic of conversation
and what struck me is the first time i
played them and i had seen them before
obviously you know he plated magics
Midsummer Night's magic the very first
year and has met him once there but to
actually like lace up my tennis shoes
and getting ready for jump ball and
being on the court with him when you
walk up to Larry Bird it's not like he
is a small 69 he is a big 69 with long
arms and I'm like looking up at him like
oh my god this is like Larry I'm saying
just to myself when I remember in the
garden they had you know the game was
closed and they were winning I'll
remember this to the end of time um we
were shooting a free throw and I was at
half-court he walks back to me and leans
over and says keep working hard young
fellow you're going to be a good one
this is Larry Bird I mean he is mr. who
jury he's from our state saying this to
me and I'm like oh my god and what I I
look hey I'm sorry there's certain
people that you root for Larry Bird is
one of those guys i will always root for
hey safe travels to milwaukee play nice
and we'll talk to you next week yiannis
optic kupo i cannot wait yeah I cannot
wait that you been to widest kid up
close and personal you've been
practicing that pronunciation I've been
practicing yeah you know Jay kid doesn't
know how to pronounce it he said but I
don't have to he just calls him good by
his his number her initials there and
say hey G on it or the Greek freak yeah
hey get away with all of them will talk
to you next week you're the best I love
you Theodore thank you love you did it
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]